hi in this video we'll talk about
hdl and reverse cholesterol transport
mediated by hdl
hdl stands for high density lipoprotein
that means hdl has more of a protein
part
than the lipid part now let me introduce
you
about hdl so hdl has apple lipoprotein
a1 apple lipoprotein c that are the
major component
of hdl and hdl can be secreted
from both intestine and the liver
40 of the hdl is actually protein
30 percent is phospholipid and 25
percent is cholesterol
now just to compare hdl with other
lipoprotein components
hdl is known as good cholesterol so in
this video we'll try to understand why
hdl is good what's the benefit of hdl
let us compare all these lipoprotein
molecules there is chylomicron vldl idl
ldl and hdl
you can see the hdl is smaller in size
in other word they have very high
density of protein and very less amount
of fat part
so the major apple lipoproteins that
make hdl
unique is apple lipoprotein a1 which is
not present in many other
apple other particles
now coming to the composition hdl is
majorly consists of protein whereas ldl
and other particles are either more
triglyceride
or cholesterol rich and hdl can be
secreted both from liver and intestine
so we know that ldl which is also known
as
bad cholesterol deposits cholesterol
excess cholesterol
in the arteries and this increase the
risk of coronary artery diseases
and they are hence atherogenic now
in case of hdl they kind of scavenge
these excess cholesterol from these
arterial space and they return it to
liver so they are kind of
anti-atrogenic and better for our health
now hdl has several other properties
which make it unique
hdl is a resolver for apple lipoprotein
and many of these apple ipod proteins
are supplied to other
lipoprotein particles now hdl can uptake
unesterified cholesterol hdf also helps
in estrofication of cholesterol
hdl takes part in reverse cholesterol
transport that means it takes
takes away excess of cholesterol which
is deposited in the artery space and
return it to the liver
for recycling now ldl we know
already deposited excess of cholesterol
in the artery walls and
hdl moves in the circulation collect
those
excess of cholesterol and return it to
the liver
and this selective process is known as
the reverse cholesterol transport where
peripheral
cholesterol is now returned to the liver
for recycling purposes
and the cholesterol is now converted to
colic acid which would ultimately be
utilized from
bile acids right
now from ex from extra hepatic tissue
from external tissue space
cholesterol is collected with the help
of several
transporters such as abca1 which is
present in
almost all peripheral tissues now this
abca1 mediates cholesterol
export and cholesterol is converted to
cholesterol ester with the help of the
enzyme
lcat or lecithin cholesterol lacile
transferase
then this hdl particle can be actually
returned to the liver
and in the liver there is sr1b receptor
which is a scavenger receptor that
scavenge hdl particle
and thereby uptakes all the cholesterol
inside it
and release the hdl particle for next
round of scavenging
that what happens in the liver so this
is how
hdl deposits excess cholesterol in the
liver
now here is the foam cell
which is a rich source of cholesterol
and this deposits actually uh
cholesterol in the artery space now
cholesterol is uptaken by the nascent
hdl particle with the help of
abca1 and abcg1 receptor so
all of these cholesterol is actually
uptaken by the nascent hdl
but nasal hdl is eating more and more
cholesterol so it would become fat it
would become bigger and forming
hdl3 particles eventually hdl tree
particle would have
more of such cholesterol and
triglyceride and they would become
hdl2 particle finally this hdl2 particle
would be returned to the liver and would
be recycled
again back to the nascent collapse
nissan hdl
now hdl can interact with vldl particle
or idl particle and hdl
give them protein whereas vldl and ideal
particle give them triglycerides
ultimately after taking triglycerides
from vldl and ideal
these particle can eventually become ldl
now ldl can deposit
cholesterol in the tissues but the other
fate of ldl that it can be up taken
by the liver inside the liver there are
liver hepatocyte cells
which have ldl receptors these ldl
receptors
leads to receptor mediated endocytosis
and uptake
of cholesterol so in other way
hdl kind of indirectly favors the
cholesterol uptake
so there are two pathways by hdl
mediates these cholesterol uptake one
via these ldl particles or otherwise
directly binding to the scavenger
receptor present in the
liver hepatocytes so in this video we
overall looked at
that hdl works like a garbage picking
truck so wherever there is a garbage
it picks it up and put it in the dump
yard here the dump beard is analogous to
the liver
whereas the garbage which is sitting
around near the road is actually
the cholesterol present in the arterial
plux
which is picked up by the hdl particle
and these excess cholesterol is
deposited into the liver and thereby
efficient recycling is happening which
prevents our
body from the risk of atherogenesis i
hope you enjoyed this video if you like
this video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe thank
you